[Musique]
il y à 100 ans en mars 1918 au kansas
dans un camp militaire
une grippe foudroie les soldats si le
début de la grippe espagnole de la
grande tueuse les américains bientôt
l'heure de s'engager dans la première
guerre mondiale
les jeunes soldats convergent par
milliers vers des camps infectées avant
de s'entasser dans des bateaux vers
l'europe
c'est à l'automne que la grippe devient
meurtrière de jeunes soldats meurent du
jour au lendemain
à la fin de la guerre et milliers de
soldats retournent dans leur pays
l'influenza est disséminée sur tous les
continents jusqu'à un tiers de la
population mondiale auraient été
affectés les évaluations du nombre de
décès sont grossières 50 millions
peut-être 100 millions une chose est
sûre la grippe a tué bien plus que la
grande guerre à l'aune de 1919 la grippe
la plus mortelle de l'histoire disparaît
aussi soudainement qu'elle est apparue
on connaît aujourd'hui le visage de la
meurtrière un virus le h1n1 les
scientifiques ont ressuscité d'entre les
morts d'une victime déterré d'une fosse
commune en alaska
le virus a été séquencé reconstruit et
étudier
[Musique]
cette analyse génétique permet de
résoudre la plus grande énigme de la
grippe espagnole les grippe tue
habituellement les plus jeunes et des
personnes âgées
la grippe espagnole elle tuait des
adultes dans la vingtaine
dans la force de l'âge en analysant les
grippes passé les chercheurs se sont
rendu compte que ces adultes étaient
particulièrement vulnérables car leur
première grippe celle à laquelle ils ont
été exposés pendant leur enfance était
une grippe passagère la grippe russe qui
avait sévi entre 1889 et 1900 causée par
le virus h3n2 8
le reste de la population quant à elle
avait été exposée durant l'enfance un
des grippes apparenté à la grippe
espagnole avec la protéine h 1
c'est une leçon qui pourrait servir
lorsqu'une nouvelle grippe émergera
entre autres pour protéger les
générations les plus vulnérables et ne
pas répéter les erreurs du passé
[Musique]